hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my playthrough of the
Stanley parable now this is actually a
very interesting game that's been on my
list for a while it's not really horror
it's not really anything that you've
ever played before in fact I don't
really know I know there's like a
narrator in you gotta like make choices
but I've always wanted to play and I
decided it's about damn time that I did
so let's get into it I'm just pretty
excited cuz my brother told me good
things about him I heard a bit of things
about it not kidding this is the story
of a man named Stanley hey Stanley
worked for a company in a big building
where he was employee number four to
seven sounds good employee number four
to seven s job was simple he sat at his
desk in room four to seven and he pushed
buttons on a keyboard
ah orders came to him through a monitor
next to his desk telling him what
buttons to push
how long to push them and in what order
ah this is what employee four to seven
did every day of every month of every
year and although others might have
considered its sole renting Stanley
relished every moment that the orders
came in as though he had been made
exactly for this job and Stanley was
happy
and then one day something very peculiar
happened something that would forever
change Stanley something he would never
quite forget okey-dokey
he had been at his desk for nearly an
hour when he realized that not one
single order had arrived on a monitor
for him to follow no one had showed up
to give him instructions call a meeting
or even say hi never in all his years of
the company had this happened this
complete isolation something was very
clearly wrong yes sharp Tilly frozen
solid
Stanley found himself unable to move for
the longest time but as he came to his
wits and regained his senses he got up
from his desk and walked out into the
hallway now the premise of this game
that I know is that you have choices to
make you can follow the narrator's
instructions or not
I can't even jump so and obviously it is
made on the sausage Stanley decided to
go to the staff lounge to check on his
co-workers he never functioned well by
himself and constantly needed support
and guidance from others these are the
thoughts of total solitude was
terrifying to it
hmm hello four to five hello four to
four oh four to four you're not there
hello four to three when Stanley came to
a set of two open doors he entered the
door on his left yeah this is where the
essence of the game comes in because you
can listen to the narrator or you can go
on your own thing let me I don't even
think you can oh you can you can't say
here we go screw you narrator this was
not the correct way to the employee
lounge and Stanley knew it perfectly
well so he turned left at the first open
door and walked back in the right
direction nope screw you
uh-uh ain't gonna happen nope ah Stan II
was so bad at following directions it's
incredible he wasn't five years ago
maybe this is why everyone had left no
one wanted to be around someone as bad
at listening as him and since he was
walking into the middle of nowhere and
that's ruining the entire story Stanley
decided that he would punish himself so
when he came to the elevator and the
doors opened he stepped inside and
pushed the button to go up hmm it's like
a choose-your-own-adventure
with kind of a creepy narrator who seems
to get irritated any down yeah
Oh Stanley you know you really aren't
going anywhere and I don't say that
deceitfully I truthfully mean that there
isn't a story down here the story was
back up where I told you to go in the
first place right now you're just
running around looking at empty halls
and frankly that's perhaps even more
infuriating for me so why don't you
throw me a bone give me a chance and
just let me tell the story I want to
tell em no ah I could narrate this story
twice as good as you Stanley walked down
into the hallway into bit it in the pit
fine fine you can oh hello
now listen
carefully this is important Stanley
walked through the red door
oh this blue door I like blue ah Stanley
walked through the red door no blue yes
ha ha suck on that even Mary I still
don't think I'm communicating properly
ah honey walked through the red door ah
ha ha oh you missed oh oh ha ha yup
alright fine go ahead Stanley you want
to know so badly what's out there you
want to find out what lies at the end of
this road you've chosen well don't let
me stop you
oh I won't whoa what guff you see ah
it's nothing no one's even built this
second than that because you were never
supposed to be here in the first place
it's just a bunch of skybox and dev wall
textures that's it
is this what you were looking for yep
was it worth ruining the story I'd
written out for you absolutely
I put a lot of time into that and now
you well here you are now just looking
at nothing to think that that's all I
needed to make in the first place just a
whole lot of nothing and you would have
been happy well hey you still need a
little something to do yeah am i right
here let me load up another map see if
there's something in here that'll keep
you occupied okay mr. man ah here's one
let's boot this up we'll see if you like
it I bet I will oh hello loading screen
I like to skim I probably should be a
bit more cooperative oh hello no no way
what Victor well Stanny oh I don't know
why it would be this map wasn't even
made for you know almost I created a
world specifically with you in mind
I think I wanted to make you a leading
man this one well I'm afraid you're on
your own
okay I can deal with that we am Gordon
from man I'm gonna save the day by
obeying the g-man ha ha oh yeah
oh yeah Oh put the can in trash that's
not this part yet does it that's later
Stanley was fat and ugly really really
stupid
hey she Toby only got his job because of
a family connection I have no cheaper
phasing that or with drug money yes I'm
also Stan is addicted to drugs and
hookers I'll make my own game with
blackjack and hookers screw you man you
don't even know what's good for you or
me hey let me is that another employee I
don't know I want to go to Nova Prospekt
ah alright fine I'll going to the
interview Barney
buy me a beer hey were you doing that
guy in there okay bye Oh blood all right
dr. kleiner kleiner put a sport I spent
so long talking about you why don't we
just take a break from that and talk
about something else for a change but I
love talking about me well according to
Wikipedia more than 90% of the night
sharks caught off northeastern Brazil
contain mercury concentrations higher
than that considered safe by the local
government now this is fascinating yeah
don't you want to know more about the
night shot absolutely no no of course
not I do all you want to hear about is
yourself well that too yeah I am I'll
fine you haven't listened to me once so
far lissa hell I can't expect you to
turn that around now can I nope not at
all are you that are you actually
letting me go I know how to beat this
part ah let adder I take one of these
boxes with me no reason is this the end
of the line what the hell and suppose
this was a particularly fulfilling
experience for severing not a single art
aspect in this map was creative with you
in mind
aha
hey you're a creative kid I am my Betty
you can come up with a story about this
place while you're in it yeah while
you're doing that why don't you think of
an ending to a figure because you
certainly won't find one here
I'm afraid that's the long and short of
it this room and these walls are all you
get nope
I see oh maybe the story ends when you
decide you can't live in this futuristic
science fiction dystopia well I like can
you honestly commit suicide
no that doesn't sound maybe you stand in
this spot for all of eternity to guide
and greet other travelers like yourself
who pass this way or maybe you just get
bored and you quit the game nope thing
could happen heck anything's an ending
if that's where you stop playing but
whatever ending you write for yourself
Stanley you won't have my help you
turned your back on me yeah now I do the
same to you shut up so why need be luck
I think you'll need it
and I sincerely hope that everyone lives
happily ever after ah not gonna happen
see here we go hey wait ow
hold on what are you what are you doing
ow my legs hey look there's a little
this is light hang on there's something
here Stanny don't do that I can't follow
you there I can't help you shut up you
were helping me before
shut up I'm already doing it who hello
Oh huh say wha say whoa piggy I like
this game oh hello 425
hello 424 hello 423 oh this old choice
again shall I be forever stuck in the
same old loop that which I was always
with which and then I went or should I
go on my own way I still want to go this
way or is there nothing to this way hmm
there's no narrator the doors aren't
slamming behind me I bet no elevator
pops up hmm I guess I gotta go that way
hmm huh it's sad I know but all stories
must come to an end of course they say
it's the journey that truly matters and
not the destination and I like that idea
to think we might value the paths we
walk as much as the places they lead us
okay now I don't know what sort of story
you've ciphered out of that world you've
made for yourself but I hope that being
the leading man was everything it's
cracked up to be it was I know it can be
a little hard getting around without
someone looking over your shoulder but
this is simply the nature of freedom
besides I haven't really gone anywhere
maybe you don't want a guy do
but I think I'll always have a place
here at the end of every story okay I'll
step in and wrap things up with a nice
piece of dialogue and a reflectional
life that makes sense of whatever path
you've chosen to walk out here today and
for now I'm happy to be the destination
instead of the journey but only for now
only for now away haha I like that I
like that a lot that's really cool I
mean to be perfectly honest there's a
lot of choices that have to do with the
game like a lot of choices but I don't
have time to go through all the other
choices just yet um unless I decide to
make this alone now I don't have all the
time to make the choices for the other
path just with that was actually really
cool I like that I also like that the
narrator was a really good voice actor
and it's just these experimental games
are what really really drive my passion
for video games I love these little
nuances like this and I wish I'd have
played this a long time ago either way
that was awesome um you can find uh the
Stanley parable on ModDB or in the link
in the description below thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done um let me know in the comments if
you want me to go down the other path or
you can do it for yourself which might
be even better and more fun so let me
know in the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye